HENRY SHACKLETON: So
in this classroom,
we had sort of a flipped
format where before every lab
you'd go through questions
online, watch presentation
videos online.
And I think that really helped
because lab classes sort
of inherently when you're
doing the analysis,
doing all the data collection,
they're very independent.
So you don't have a professor
telling you do this, do that.
You're on your own doing
this data collection.
And the fact that
the pre-lab, sort
of going through and
learning the stuff,
you do that by yourself as well.
You sort of independently
learn all this stuff
and research by yourself and
find out things by yourself.
That sort of helps to lead you
into the ultimate data analysis
and making a presentation by
yourself and doing all of this
independently.